[Applause]
meagan mark old the Duchess of Sussex
put her baby bump on full display as she
visited the Royal Variety residential
nursing and care home Bryn's birth house
the Duchess is stunned in a
figure-hugging of floral dress and chic
wrap coat all paired with suede heels a
coordinated silk clutch and a set of
stellar diamond studs all together the
look retails for more than four thousand
dollars inside the nursing home Meghan
bonded with residents the Bryn's birth
house is home to retired entertainers
who require assisted living the Duchess
who is of course a retired actress
herself chatted with her fellow former
performers sharing it this update with
one new friend Meghan went on to do a
little arts and crafts tour the
facilities even giving one woman a shock
in the salon along the way jhaza met
with the cooks and sat back and watched
a holiday performance
[Music]
but the visit sadly couldn't last
forever Megan had to say goodbye after a
couple hours
[Music]